we are back with our co-host Tay Diggs
thank you Tay and we're here
uh celebrating the spring edition of
Drew magazine that's right and our next
guest is featured in the latest issue
and according to her eating homegrown
greens just tastes better so she's here
to teach us how to build our own herb
garden please welcome the host of
homegrown and the owner of Patchwork
City Farms Jamila
[Applause]
yes so we're planting an herb garden
today and we have a bunch of beautiful
herbs here and um most important thing
lots of sun do not skimp out on the
amount of sun that your herbs need they
will be scraggly if you don't okay great
soil so we need some good soil and we've
already got some soil in here so we're
just gonna take your soil add some more
to The Container to compost soil or not
compost soil the compost you make at
home is an amendment to the soil that
you buy but I would not make that the
base right so buy good soil organic as
possible with lots of nutrients okay
when you say compost does that mean is
that doo-doo no no I mean you know on a
farm it could be okay so next we're
going to talk about some seeds so people
are like what should I what should I
plant what you love I was gonna say do
what you like what's the difference
between transplants and seeds okay
perfect so obviously seeds are you know
what you're going to use to kind of
start your plant and then with
transplants they've already been started
they already have roots on them and um
it's just kind of like easy and it's
ready to go you can break it it's fine
you can break it or you can try tap in
from the bottom that from the bottom and
it just drops right out I got rosemary
you got rosemary yeah oh and you're
almost intact but what I like to do is I
like to kind of just stage everything
with what I want is it true that you
should kind of break up the roots a
little bit yes you should let me show
you let me show you right you see how
this rosemary plant came out and all the
roots are kind of stuck at the bottom
yeah yeah
and you want to open it up so that when
it gets in the container or you know
whatever you're planting it in it kind
of expands out so next thing you water
most herbs don't like a ton I was gonna
say how much water because I feel like I
over water because I overdo everything
yeah everything I go so hard I know
please don't over water I know
I don't have subtle tea in me don't know
each other I'm doing better though right
I'm doing better yeah
um first
um herb was like a crime scene and now I
feel like I'm I'm in the swing of things
a bit more yeah yeah you're doing great
and let me show you show you how to
plant some seeds right so this is the
cilantro seed yeah it's really easy and
literally you just kind of like sprinkle
them sprinkle a little bit you don't
need much right because each seed is
going to be one big plant right and just
sprinkle some soil on top you Tamp it
for five or six all right well Jamila I
cannot thank you enough for showing how
to do this because what you do on your
show and in this magazine is you bring
us on a journey to show that we can do
it and we can live that life so thank
you thank you you're welcome all right
will you catch the first two seasons of
homegrown on HBO Max and Discovery plus
and up next we pack our bags perfectly
or we try to and we'll be right back
thank you
foreign